[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour on va commencer par la genèse je
suis né en 1944 pas par 1910 la mort
ça veut dire que j'ai été élevé par des
gens du 19e siècle qui m'ont seulement
aimer mais qui ont voulu mêler levé
comme il l'avait été eux mêmes c'est à
dire que on ne fait pas naître une
personne particulière on forme l'enfant
à l'image de ce que doit être la famille
et moi ça m'allait pas du tout alors ben
alors j'obéissais mais j'étais rien en
même temps ce qui m'a sauvé je pense
c'est que j'avais un rêve que j'ai eues
mais très très tôt très tôt
je voulais écrire et puis je voulais
aussi remonté l'amazone j'avais vu le
nom dans un atlas ça me faisait rêver
et puis éventuellement me marier avec
burt lancaster parce qu'il était quand
même très bon donc j'ai eu une éducation
bourgeoise comme il faut dû payer tes
parents tu te mariera en blanc tu auras
des enfants qui offrira ta souffrance à
dieu etc et j'ai fait des études j'ai
fait des études de lettres que mes
parents m'ont offert c'était un très
beau cadeau et j'ai cherché un métier où
on écrit le journalisme s'était pas
vraiment ouvert et je suis rentré dans
la publicité
c'était marrant comme tout je faisais
des messages radio 90mo 30 secondes et
cetera et cetera
j'ai fait joli petit carrière et puis tu
arrives et mai 68
alors bon ça a été génial mai 68 les
femmes ont le droit d'exister
l'individu a le droit d'exister mais il
y avait plus de transports en commun ou
moi fallait que je marche énormément
entre mon appartement et bureaux
j'avais aucun permis de rien
j'étais efficace j'allais m'acheter une
moto mais pas une moto parce que j'avais
pas de père mais c'était en réalité
cb 50 ans d'art un vélomoteur on appelle
ça une tasse à café ou une mouche à
merde au choix je suis allé rouler sur
ma petite de wanda et c'était génial
c'était l'espace quand est arrivé le
mois de septembre je prenais toujours
mes vacances en septembre j'ai annoncé
aux copains à lagence allez je vais
aller voir la méditerranée je n'ai
jamais vu
ah ça m'aide bien et folle c'est pas ça
c'est impossible et tout seul
bah ouais ben alors bon je montais sur
ma petite moto et à 60 à l'heure suis
allée de paris jusqu'à la méditerranée
les enfants c'était le paradis
et puis je suis rentré et puis j'ai
repris ma carrière et puis j'ai passé
mon permis moto et puis j'ai eu les
motos de plus en plus puissantes et
c'était toujours génial au mois de
septembre
au point qu'un jour je me suis dit mais
attends 11 mois de ta vie tu es heureuse
et le 12e tu es très très heureuse alors
quand tu vas mourir c'est quoi
l'addition et j'ai commencé à étouffer
et imaginez-vous qu'en 1972
je prends le papier parce que vous savez
j'ai des trous de mémoire je préfère
blindés 1
j'ai toujours roulé avec un casque et en
1972 s'organise le premier raid moto
vers l'orient parisse par an je
m'inscris à ce raid
tout le monde me dit mais il faut pas
lilla papp c'est des fous tu vas te
faire assassiner violer tu vas finir
dans un baril de pétrole à abu dhabi et
cetera je tire je préfère encore ça que
de rester dans une vie où j'ai tout fait
on me prête une moto comme une 750 guzzi
quand elle penchait je peux pas
l'empêcher de tomber quand elle était
par terre je peux pas la relever
mais rivet on est parti à 105 92 sont
arrivés à 10 par an gt il y en a onze
qui disent on veut en afghanistan
[Applaudissements]
après attendez attendez là c'est le
début un onze en afghanistan je les suis
5 au pakistan j'y suis et puis je
reviens en france et j'écris mon premier
livre est là mais vraiment je suis
rentré dans le paradis sur terre il y
avait mes chats ma plume mon papier un
éditeur le voyage génial au point que je
m'étais dit je peux être prendre la
publicité à moyen terme comme ça non non
c'était plus possible donc il faut que
je fasse quelque chose de très très
costaud pour qu'on prenne au sérieux et
que je puisse continuer et j'ai annoncé
que j'allais faire un tour du monde tout
seul
pourquoi tout seul parce que pendant ce
premier voyage avaient compris que les
autres étaient un écran entre mois ils
les pays que je traversais or
l'afghanistan m'avait quand même sauté
au coeur le pakistan avait sauté au
coeur la turquie de l'est ça m'avait
bouleversé et cetera et cetera mais y
avait cet écran et puis l'autre chose
c'est que quand une moto comme ça se
casse la gueule si je peux pas la
relever je risque d'être coincé au
milieu de nulle part et dans tous les
pays on peut tomber sur quelqu'un de mal
intentionné ou tout simplement mourir de
froid pendant la nuit
donc je suis parti avec une moto
minuscule 120 centimètres cubes kawasaki
mais elle roulait à 80 à l'heure celle
là et du progrès je suis partie par le
canada et l'alaska c'était un long
voyage 10 11 mille kilomètres en
principe sans trop de problème on est
pas dit qu avait deux types de 1000 km
de pistes entre le canada et l'alaska
j'arrive au japon je fais un très beau
plat ventre pour entrer dans l'usiné
kawasaki à gashi ensuite je me retrouve
en inde
et là j'étais sur une autre fan est
vraiment japon j'ai rien compris l'inde
j'ai rien compris non plus mais
c'était chaleureux il y avait des titres
qu'il tapait dans les ans hier kommt et
crazy mensah ribes qui s'en allait
j'adorais ça qu'est ce que vous voulez
et puis j'arrive au pakistan il y avait
plein de gens partout je me disais bon
il peut rien se passer à fabian plus qu
est ce qu ils sont marrants qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont sympas il vient discuter
avec moi je passe la passe de kyle berre
et puis j'arrive à la douane afghane il
y avait plein de camionneurs avec de
merveilleux rues calmes camion peint en
rose de toutes les couleurs et moi je
suis arrivée sur la petite moto qui me
regardait puisse ont tous commencé à se
marrer il tapait dans l'épaule en disant
préparez vous aux mannes alors bon ben
je passe tout ça dans mon dieu ils sont
gentils quand même c'est un pays un peu
désert je vais y aller aujourd'hui à
kaboul
ensuite demain je vais de kaboul à
kandahar à à kandahar 540km les faits
c'est plus goudronnée kandahar est ratée
plus après tranquille bon démarre et
puis au milieu de nulle part entre la
douane et djalal-abad ma moto fait ch
pouf et c'était le pneu avant qui était
crevé alors je commence à démonter maru
difficilement arrive un des premiers
camions qui m'avait dit verrez vous mène
à la douane
problème on aurait bien tout va bien
tout va bien alors ils s'en vont
deuxième camion pareil troisième camion
arrive demande même pas s'arrête et
trois armoires à glace en turban
descendent visage fermé bon bah je me
dis ça y est si j'ai joué j'ai perdu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le premier m'attrape par les épaules il
m'a scié par terre les deux autres ont
changé ma roue et le premier est resté
entre le soleil et moi pour que je n'ai
pas trop chaud quand c'était fini ils
m'ont tapé dans l'épaule et ils ont dit
very brévaux man
[Applaudissements]
je vous assure que pour la première fois
de ma vie j'ai eu honte j'ai eu honte
d'avoir cru toutes les conneries qu'on a
pu me dire j'ai eu honte de penser que
ces gens n'avaient pas d'honneur j'ai
pensé que parce qu'il avait la peau
sombre
je ne pensais pas on me l'avait dit mais
je ne l'avais pas de nettoyer de ma tête
et c'est ça ce que j'aurais dû faire et
c'est de ça que géantes c'est de m'être
laissé imprégner par des conneries
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et du coup je vais aller me balader en
afghanistan et j'ai adoré ce pays et
j'ai adoré ces gens et j'adorais ses
paysages et les gens venaient me voir
j'étais la télé en couleur pour eux
parce que vous imaginez quand même que
dans des pays où les femmes sont voilées
en voit arriver une nana toute seule sur
une moto et qui en plus se marre mais
attendez c'était fabuleux
le nombre de fois pendant ce voyage dans
ces pays où on me disait que c'était des
sauvages iran la turquie l'afghanistan
le pakistan ou je déjeunais dans un
châle rana dans un petit restaurant au
bord de la route et où au moment de
payer on disait ah non non non quelqu'un
l'a fait pour vous et tu ne savais pas
qui vous imaginez qu'on fasse ça en
france pour un maghrébin pour quelqu'un
qui vient du pakistan non ils sont dans
la rue
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est un cadeau que vous faites et
j'ai continué ma vie comme ça je me suis
promené en australie j'ai adoré
l'australie j'ai passé sept mois en
amérique du sud j'ai adoré le perron
j'ai eu une vie de rêve où je me
baladais je me casser la gueule avec mes
motos bien entendu j'avais toujours pas
le permis voiture je rigolais comme une
feuille je rentrais j'écrivais mes
livres c'est vrai que je tombe bien peu
amoureuse de temps à autres aussi je
vois par tête
et puis en 81
le gouvernement mitterrand a mis en
place le carnet de change en face à
c'était un contrôle des changes donc on
aurait pu sortir l'argent de france donc
je pouvais pu voyager du coup j'ai écrit
des romans et ça a été passionnant
d'écrire des romans et de nouveau j'ai
continué à être heureuse est ce que je
n'avais pas compris pendant mes voyages
et je n'avais pas compris de moi aussi
profond mon travail de roman ça a été un
travail d'analysé fabuleux mais les
voyages à moto il était oublié c'est
vrai que je faisais des tas de
reportages toujours sur ma moto mais
s'ils voulaient toutes cette grande saga
c'était loin imaginez vous que en 2016
kerouay keller qui était à cette époque
la styliste de la maison de couture
chloé me demande si elle peut utiliser
quelques phrases de mon tour du monde
donc 10 à 45 ans pour sa collection
automne hiver 2016 2017 la mode bien sûr
et elle fait une collection qui
s'appelle les motardes romantique et
jamais aucune collection n'a eu autant
de presse à travers le monde entier
jusqu'en corée du sud
j'ai vu sur internet et cliquer critique
écrit en asticots avec juste mon ombre
en vrai en france d'autres villes et
voilà qu'elle avait ouvert mon cercueil
que ce tour du monde que j'avais fait
joyeusement légèrement est ressorti et
les ressorties parce que je crois que
nos sociétés en rêve
depuis je suis souvent invité à droite à
gauche pour raconter mon voyage mais
autre voyage pour rencontrer des gens et
je vois arriver des garçons des filles
de 20 ans de 30 ans qui me disent qu'est
ce que ce qu'est ce qu'on voudrait vivre
ça qu'est-ce qu'il rêve de ce monde qui
était léger qui était joyeux et où au
fond les impossible avait un peu explosé
eh bien je crois que si j'en rêve ils
refont ce monde là parce que quand une
société rêve
elle réalise elle mais le temps quelques
fois il ya plein de choses à nettoyer
mais c'est reviendra un jour alors vous
voyez entre les impossible de ne pas
exister en tant que moi même
l'impossible d'aller en afghanistan
l'impossible de trucs l'impossible de
machin bon maintenant je suis regardé
dans mon papier parce que ça c'est au
fond mes petites recettes mes voyages je
m'en tape et donc comment on explose dès
impossible la possibilité de se
rencontrer
alors il faut faire passer la curiosité
mais après la prudence parce que partout
il ya des règles du jeu et avant labeur
et la clé c'est tu es qui toi et ça
marche dans les deux sens quand on dit
tu es qui toi on ouvre le coeur de
l'autre on s'intéresse à lui et le voit
l'impossibilité de s'accepter
chaque peuple est un individu il a mis
des siècles à se construire
il a son identité vérité en deçà des
pyrénées erreur au-delà écrivait pascal
il faut accepter la diversité
impossible de se comprendre on peut pas
vraiment se comprendre quand moi je dis
je en occident je dis moi tout seul dans
le temps dans l'univers moi tout seul
quand on dit je en orient c'est moi ma
famille mon clan ma religion
mes amis on n'a pas le même jeu alors on
communique par les racines
et ça je vous assure que c'est fabuleux
c'est émouvant c'est généreux c'est
sincère impossible de partager faut pas
demander trop faut pas demander trop
parce qu'on vit pas de la même manière
on n'a pas les mêmes codes mais
simplement un regard
sourire et ça c'est gigantesque c'est le
signe qu'on se respecte et qu'on accepte
maintenant il ya un seul un possible
auquel je tiens et je ne veux pas qu'ils
disparaissent c'est la construction
d'une seule vérité pour le monde entier
de l'uniformité
si la différence qui fait que l'on se
pose des questions qu'on cherche l'autre
et que en cherchant la différents
reconnaissant la différence on reconnaît
par où on se ressemble et c'est comme ça
qu'on est des humains et c'est ce que
j'ai appris le derrière sur ma moto du
cambouis sous des angles et le vent dans
les oreilles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]